[Music]
welcome back everybody to another pi
data global
sponsor interview i'm james powell i
serve as
co-chair of the non-focus board of
directors and also as vice president of
pi data
today we're going to be speaking to ana
salamudi from mozin
a little bit about how they contribute
back to the open source community
why that motivates mozin and us to be
more active participants in the pi data
community what that might mean
for the individual career of a junior
programmer
why anas is so excited about
scikit-learn and why scikit-learn has
really changed his life
and a bunch of other topics so anas
would you like to introduce yourself to
the pi data global community
sure um my name is anna salamodi um
i've been working on with software for
over 12 years now
moved between the mobile application and
got into the
data science and then moved to the
software engineering
board and became an application more
like of uh
[Music]
software engineer in general i can do
anything now
i found i co-founded a startup back in
2015
and we we got acquired um two years ago
and then i started to look up more
i mean opportunities in the scene and
now i'm working at muslim
as the lead engineer and helping um the
company
achieve their goals when it comes to
developing
applications for enterprise and
government and anas would you like to
introduce mozin to everybody
mozun is a great uh company it's a
company that
um develop application
based on data we we approach our
solutions
by first finding um looking at data and
analyzing data
and based on what we find we develop
solutions we know that it's going to
benefit
the our clients this is how museum
works and this is how muslims strive to
to
deliver values to our clients
so anas could you tell me a little bit
about what open source tools from the pi
data or the python ecosystem that you
use at mozin
at mozun we use a lot of open source
libraries one of them is
pandas and scikit-learn
mainly we use this tool with the jupiter
notebooks
to work on the initial analysis of the
data
we try to understand how we process
these data and how we work with it
um once the solution is ready um
it helps us a lot in developing the the
actual application for the clients
and in the same time it's it makes
the process easier to analyze the data
do you work with a lot of big data sets
yes we
uh we work with a lot of the big data
from
different clients some of it are very
sensitive to work with so
and it's very private so we have to be
on premise sometimes to work on it
um which makes it a bit harder for us to
to analyze and what help us the most is
having these tools
um that we're using
um and we have also our own internal
modules um
built on top of it which help us as well
in
integrating with the data in a shorter
time
and be more efficient in uh
understanding
what's behind the data and how can we
find patterns within the data
that can help us in developing the
solutions for the client
so what's your favorite open source tool
i love
cyclic layer i used psychic length early
on when i was
in my career back in 2011
i started working with scikit-learn as
a as just learning machine learning
and then um i loved it because
it was well documented it was easy to
use
it was open source so we can work on it
um and i kept working on it until i
founded my startup back in 2015
um um i also used scikit-learn to
develop the first solution
to uh work on on the research part of it
i use it in my master degree as well um
which was like a big point in my career
and then one thing i also what i
mentioned is that
i was in pi data 2015 in new york here
and i attended a talk to uh that andreas
mate was one of the authors of second
learn
and i just at that point i was i wanted
to contribute
to uh to the library and i work with it
um but i never had the chance but um
that the psychic learn i guess it's my
favorite here
that's fantastic what motivates you to
want to give back to
open source tools like succulent it's
exactly the same
moment when i was like a young
early on in my career looking at open
source library like psychic learn
it helps you a lot in in unders
i mean it helped me a lot in my career
early on and i want to
have that and give that to the community
and i want people to
interact with it and work with it as
well
so you've attended pi data events before
what is
the aspect of the pi data community that
attracts you the most
it's like a big family this is what i
liked it i liked when i went there i
felt like
it's an amazing atmosphere everyone is
was friendly and helpful
no one was like holding back information
or data
in fact everyone was like excited to
share with you
and talk to you about their tools and
their projects
and they would talk to you also about
like how can you
resolve their problems and how can you
overcome any obstacles you might find
i met a lot of interesting people there
and uh
i'm still in contact with some of them
which was um
great that and now in my career i'm at
the point where
i'm actually talking to you guys and
interviewing with my data my company is
sponsoring my data which is something
makes me very proud and i'm very happy
to to be able to
be part of giving back to this community
so i understand one of your colleagues
at mozin is going to be presenting at pi
data global would you like to tell us a
little bit about what they'll be
speaking on
um we're going to talk about
one of the libraries we're working on
internally which is name matching
it's about how arabic names are written
in english
or english names are written in arabic
it's a very interesting talk
because this is uh it wasn't it's not
available anywhere else in the world
and the way that the guys developed it
in um
at museum it's it's very interesting the
way they
uh um came up with an algorithm
and uh and text analysis part there's a
lot of nlp
work in there that can enable the
us to change so you know that when you
when you translate names it's very hard
so the way you write the name in english
can be
can be in different ways for one name in
arabic um
so that that that's uh one of the things
that actually
um empowered muslim to develop more
around data and have more
solutions around data when num focus
talks about giving back to
the pi data community or giving back to
the community they mean this very
broadly and there's a number of
different ways that somebody can do this
you could volunteer an event you could
attend an event as you have in past
you could give back to a project you
could speak at an event as one of your
colleagues is speaking
you could sponsor a pi data conference
or an unfocused as your organization
is and i'm curious for you personally
what motivates you to give back to the
community how does that benefit you
in your life there's no doubt that
supporting an open source project
can be very helpful to your career
because you're showcasing your ability
and your work to the public
and this is how i always
advise my junior engineers when i'm
working with them
i always advise them to go ahead and
support
the community go ahead and showcase your
work
your intelligence and your ability to
understand and work with other people
online and show it to the rest of the
world there is no shame in making
mistakes because everyone makes mistakes
but hiding and not showing your work and
trying to protect everything
is not going to benefit you as much also
personally speaking i gained a lot of
knowledge through this
libraries and open source communities
and i want to give back
i want to be supportive as well because
this is how
we grow as a community and helped
help the rest of the engineering
communities
um gain knowledge and develop their
skills
when you're recruiting new junior
engineers at mozin
do you look towards the community
contributions they've made and does that
reflect
positively on those candidates of course
um
this is one of the things we always uh i
mean
have an eye for whenever someone apply
for a job
if you have an open source contribution
to one of these libraries
we're definitely hiring because the
to be able to get to a point where you
can actually
um contribute uh by a pull request or
um defining a solution for an open
source library that means you were able
to
go there interact with the code
understand how other people works and
get your work approved
by the community which is
something that is you can't even
validate within an interview session
that's why um it's very important for us
to have people
can understand and work with open source
libraries if you are speaking to a
colleague at a different organization
who is on the fence about sponsoring a
pi data conference
how might you convince them that it
would be worth the time the effort the
money
so one of the main benefits about
supporting
i mean pay data and be uh being a
sponsor for big data
is that you send a message to all the
engineers the good engineers
in the in the in the market that we are
we want to be part of the open source
community
and we are supporting open source
projects
and we want to be part of that um
and this is by itself is a good way to
attract good engineers to the market
to the company as well is the
promise of greater community interaction
and community contribution
is what one of the things that attracted
you to working at mozin
yes one of the things that makes me
excited
and it's been a while since i was
excited to work on a project
um was the idea of
uh open working on an open source
project and
especially when it comes to the
languages i'm always have been
passionate about natural language
processing
and the idea of being
able to release a work that can
enhance the natural language processing
tooling
for the arabic language and the way we
are
interacting with it in the in the open
source community now
that would be great as far as i know
there is no good library out there for
open source library that support
the language and this is an opportunity
for us to
um help and support the comm the rest of
the world
by releasing this set of tools that we
already have in-house
to the rest of the world to be you know
open for contributions
also um to be used in research and
analysis
so i understand that mozin is hiring
what kind of profiles
are you looking for what kind of roles
are you trying to fill we have an
amazing data science team
and we're we also have a great software
engineering team
which is the team i'm leading and we're
looking
to hire more intelligent people
um that can have an eye for uh
solutions within data and i'm really
hoping that we can
we have the best of the best in saudi
our one of my
personal goals is to have the best team
in the middle east
and we always looking to hire the best
people
basically so we have a really hard
and interesting hiring process and
uh just to make sure that whoever is
going to join our team
is going to be um a remarkable person
with them
um exceptional talents and they can
and um also because we're working on a
lot of sensitive projects with
governments and
uh and uh and enterprise companies
we want these um people to be able to
expand their uh they're going to be
challenged
with these projects because it's unusual
projects and in different
uh environments is aptitude
and proficiency with python uh key
criteria for the people that you're
looking for
yes um python is one of the fundamental
things that
they must know but um
as an engineer i believe that if you
work with any other
language and you have diversity in
languages you can work with any language
which is something i uh so it's not like
a hard
requirement for me but um it's a it's a
plus for sure
would you like to give everybody a
sample of the kinds of projects that you
work on
so one of the solutions that we we have
in uh in at
museum is falcon which is a sanction
section screening
solution which is basically help
fintech companies in uh screening their
database or
incoming requests with the sanctioned
lists worldwide which is uh
helpful when it comes especially we
added the name matching part to it
so if there is an arabic name that
you're trying to
check if it's in the list or not and you
have a different spinning
right now there is no solution that can
find it for you
in in the database so um focal can add
that edge to your
solution it can provide the companies
with
more comfort and assurance that whatever
names
for formation of the name you you got
we're gonna find it from the in the list
and we're gonna help you
organize it and and make sure you
mitigate the risk out of it and the
solution is basically
i mean going back to your question how
this project is going to be i mean
it's engineered is basically we uh as
we do with all the our projects we do
work on at muzon
we develop the data science parts and
do finish the research and then we move
to the
um moving this code and the research the
production
um to to be in a full-blown application
and that's uh um what we we're looking
for we're looking for people who can
actually
work on the data science research and
dig deeper in the data and find the
patterns and find the solutions
and we need other people also to take
that
and understand it and how can we make
sure it's going to work on a large scale
for companies
so tell me a little bit more about the
culture you've helped build
at mozin at museum we really care about
people
one of the things i i learned in the
silicon valley and here
in working with the u.s companies
startups especially that
people are the core of business and if
you have
good culture if you if you if you care
about
their career and help them achieve their
goals in their career
this is how you have a healthy team
so anas would you like to leave the pi
data global community with any final
words
just enjoy the conference and
don't miss our talk about name matching
and i hope you enjoy the the conference
um so i'd like to thank anas for joining
us today
i think it was a fantastic conversation
and i'd like to thank mozin for being a
sponsor of pi data global
thank you everybody for joining us and i
hope you enjoyed our conversation
[Music]
you